So now that we have an overview of the
business model canvas in customer development,
there's some optional reading for the next lecture.
Take a look at business model generation,
pages 86 through 111
and pages 135-145.
In the Startup Owner's Manual,
take a look at pages 51 to 84 about market size,
and then take a look at pages 188 to 199
and pages 457 to 459.
Also take a look at the links below
and 4 additional readings that don't require any of the textbooks.
So that's the reading,
but what you should really be doing
if you want to build a startup
before the next lecture.
Well, what we want you to do is start working on
identifying your market size
of total available market
and what's your target market?
and then we want you to think about
what kind of a experiments would you want to use
to test your value proposition,
customer segment, channel and revenue model?
How would you go on about doing this?
Not just talking to people,
but what would you ask them, and what would be a pass/fail signal
for each test?
Some examples for the next class
are available on the link below.
The other thing you need to be doing
or the most important thing you need to be doing in between lectures
is talking to customers,
and if you're not talking to at least 10 potential customers
between these lectures,
you're really not gonna have enough mass,
enough to actually get some insights.
You can say, "Well, I've talked to 3,"
but you know,
there's no magic number, but it just turns out
that you want a data set large enough
that you can actually get not only the mainstream thought,
but some of the out lyers, or some of the interesting answers are.
So the other thing is after you talk to customers,
you want to every week, update your business model canvas
with what you've learned.
Which hypotheses were wrong and which were right?
And optionally, if you're using the LaunchPad Central software,
post your first discovery narratives.